je sais pas vraiment comment j'ai
atterri
ici foncer sans
réfléchir et finir par me perdre en
route je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est
l'histoire de ma
vie je crains vos
Majesté que l'intérêt pour la vie privée
de la princesse n'est pas prês de
s'éteindre
la presse est constamment à notre
Ousse tout ce que nous voulons pour elle
c'est qu'elle trouve la
[Musique]
paix
maman vous allez
bien je vais
bien ces derniers temps c'est un peu la
folie
[Applaudissements]
enfin réussi ce que vous vouliez me
mettre moi et cette
maison je n
rien jamais été mon
intion face à l'émotion sucité par ce
drame la famille royale reste
silencieuse
qu'est-ce que les gens veulent de
moi que vous soyez la mère de la
nation vous avez vu les images à la
téléision don g ce dont il av besoin
partout dans le
monde il
ador ce sera le plus grand événement de
nous n jamais
[Musique]
vécu